hello and welcome to this video playing
smita 08 it's going for my standard in
45 don't really recall okay this trick
Lynam that i keep forget to look at this
again and again and again and people
play it against me and they get good
positions because I I forget to look at
it back because I with it castles b5
there is a five I think I don't have
good good square there I know then
taking it I keep forgetting this stuff i
really keep forgetting this line so it's
really mostly based on tricks but it's
six first mary did have diff I did I
screw it up again I think I have to play
d6 first it's the same thing all the way
and I simply cannot i'm unable to to
learn i always forget afterwards to
check the line and get into trouble
after probably have played the same game
earlier against the same opponent maybe
it's really possible yeah this is the
kind of stuff that white ones damage do
have do it still have something that I
can play here his idea is to take and
take up six ah it's the same thing all
over again okay can I do this without
losing
and looks terrible I mean night h 6 ER
hat is force trading I really have to
pause the proceedings and afterwards
check this bloody line with deform okay
night h6 is what I was afraid of mostly
I mean this also looks bad but I'm not
sure that I'm losing maybe I am but
let's got the worst a structure but got
two bishops yay two bishops against two
nights I'm not getting checkmated
everything's okay somewhat ok at least I
think I have a dish of we're like I had
exactly this on the board before
precisely this position ok um maybe
jettison that one and go Queenie five
next taking taking us okay
okay so I have trouble moving moving
pieces here all very awkward hmm how to
do it should t5 if there should be six
something like that on I cannot move my
bishop he ever which is really a problem
23 and to maybe trade rook trader rook
not sure that this helps but
rook t7 I have come in to see six so
that that that he cannot play I think
threatening made on G to end and
attacking the rook well that should work
so I'm able to trade a rook now as I
said I'm not sure that it does help but
maybe I can takes it too bright is there
something wrong with that I unsere and
let's take it
quince is six is slightly annoying
anyway for him even without Luke oops
why is that not good night can move to
e3 but I have ruby three
yeah wiki 3 is a big trick then I don't
know white resigns you know no trick I
still keep forgetting that bloody line
that's it's it's it's a pest it's really
a pest do I have to play 26 year first I
think something like that this position
shouldn't happen really this this stuff
it's funny that the engine actually
doesn't mind my position at all I'm
almost sure that i had this on the board
earlier in blitz maybe against the same
guy it's really possible that that sets
stretch position him check yeah it's
funny that the engine actually thinks
I'm okay it assesses the position s
equals you three and twenty five rupee
eight it's all about equal if you
believe stock fishes initial assessment
yeah still equal ish and the engine
wants to play 93 and make some sense of
covering situ at taking g74 I know I can
take the porn and em better and after
this I'm more or less winning yeah I
overlooked Queen c6 night h5 has
scissors the the engine suggestion takes
takes check check check ok an f4 has to
be played and now I can take and play
Quintus is six not sure I would have
seen that it ends like this Jan
computers line and black picks up those
pawns probably with the win can i still
keep forgetting the opening line
which is dis de following this one of
those lines that you get played again in
blitz it gets plague it gets played
against me rather often and this it is
rather harmless if black knows what is
doing but I simply always forget to look
it up and again that I'm sitting there
next game like they play that again and
I still haven't looked at it now Kevin
it seems that what I played wasn't as as
awful as I initially thought during the
game okay well thanks for watching